des zones d'ombré persistent plus d'un
an après la découverte des corps de
sophie zizou taux de ces deux enfants de
7 et 3 ans en saône et loire
l'avocat du père des deux jeunes
victimes cherchent à savoir où ils ont
pu être logés pendant les deux mois
entre le jour de leur disparition est
celui où leur voiture était retrouvée
dans le canal du centre
fanny borius anthony borloo la famille
zito attend toujours des réponses
si le suicide altruiste de sophie les
autos et ses deux enfants ne fait aucun
doute
l'avocat de la famille est convaincue
qui n'a pas eu lieu tout de suite
ils demandent aux personnes qui auraient
pu héberger sophie liam et yumi de se
manifester
on fait un appel à témoins parce que si
un témoin a hébergé se fait tuer ses
enfants qu'ils le disent qu'ils nous le
disent qu'ils nous appellent qu'il
appelle les juges ils risquent rien
c'est simplement on a besoin de
reconstruire le puzzle c'est important
pour la famille notamment pour leur
travail de résilience comme disent les
psychologues
c'est très important on doit savoir ce
qui pousse les avocats à faire ça tu
appelles c'est le témoignage de lionel
et zizou tôt le frère de vincent il a
toujours affirmé avoir vu sa belle soeur
sophie à bord de sa voiture sur la rcea
le 1er mars 2016 soit un mois après sa
disparition un témoignage qu'il
considère comme préoccupant le fait que
le frère à vincent est quelqu'un
d'extrêmement d'aplomb équilibre et
rationnelle fait qu'on ne peut pas ne
pas l'écouter ne pas l'entendre et ne
pas exploiter ce témoignage
l'avocat comme la famille 10 août au
attend maintenant que leur appel soit
entendu pour pouvoir comprendre les
raisons du passage à l'acte de sophie
s'est auto et enfin tourner la page